Pat: Welcome. On behalf of Authors
at Google, it is my privilege
to introduce philosopher and author
Rebecca Newberger Goldstein today.
Among her many honors,
Ms. Goldstein became a MacArthur
Foundation Fellow in 1996.
In awarding her her prize,
MacArthur Foundation described
her work in the following words,
Rebecca Goldstein is a writer whose
novels and short stories dramatize
the concerns of philosophy
without sacrificing the demands
of imaginative storytelling.
Her books tell a compelling story as
they describe with great compassion
and originality the interaction
of mind and heart.
In her fiction, the characters
confront problems of faith:
religious faith and faith in an ability
to comprehend the mysteries
of the physical world
as complimentary to the moral
and emotional states of being.
Goldstein's writings emerge as brilliant
arguments for the belief
that fiction in our time
may be the best vehicle
for involving readers in questions
of morality and existence.
Currently, she is a research associate
in the Department of Psychology
at Harvard University.
Ms. Goldstein is here today
to talk about her latest book
"36 Arguments for the Existence
of God: A Work of Fiction".
Following the talk,
we will have a Q&A session
and if you can remember our world
audience and speak up that'll help
and now, please join me in welcoming
Rebecca Newberger Goldstein.
[applause]
Rebecca Goldstein: Thank you, Pat,
for the introduction
and thank you who've
come to hear a novelist.
That means a lot to me actually.
I take novel writing very seriously
and I think that is in fact a way of
exploring deepful, solvable questions.
This particular novel is one that
is devoted to the long standing,
the latest installment,
of the long standing debate
between religion and science,
faith and reason.
It's about those who call themselves
the new atheists and a lot of others
and it takes place over the course of one
week with many incursions from the past.
Just like the debates themselves,
the voice of this novel is
often very noisy and raucous
and there are many large
and assertive personalities.
There is, for example,
an extreme distinguished professor
of Faith, Literature, and Values,
that is his actually title.
Extreme, distinguished,
that was the only way that
the university could lure him there
and he actually constitutes
a department of one.
He is very, very happy about this,
he doesn't have to deal
with any colleagues
and if he calls a faculty meeting,
he can boycott it and there's a woman
who is a anthropologist
and her Amazonian hunter gatherers
have dubbed her with a word
that means a whole lot of woman,
and there's a very small
mathematical genius,
mathematical geniuses tend
to populate my fiction.
This one is the son of a Hasidic rebbe,
that is a kind of very insular sect
of extremely Orthodox Jews
and the title of rebbe, head honcho,
is hereditary
so he's destined to be
the rebbe himself someday
and he is six years old.
He sees the numbers and
he thinks that they're angels.
Lots and lots of characters
in this book
and though it's actually
a very boisterous book,
it starts very quietly and I'm going to
read to you from the quiet beginning
from a sort of condensed
version of the first chapter
which is called "The Argument
from the Improbable Self".
All of the chapters in
there are thirty six of them
have names like the argument
from something weird.
The argument from the New York Times
or the argument from dapple things.
There is actually also an appendix
which is non fiction and sets forth;
I think of it as non-fiction,
it sets forth thirty-six arguments
for the existence of God.
Some of which are quite common and
some of which my character makes up
and all the arguments have rebuttals
and they are all laid out in an analytic way
and with flaws exposed.
Anyway, I'm going to read to you from
"The Argument from
the Improbable Self".
" Something shifted,
something so immense
you could call it the world,
call it the world.
The world shifted catching
lots of smart people off guard,
churning up issues you had thought had
settled forever beneath the Earth's crust.
The more sophisticated you are,
the more annotated your mental life,
the more taken a back
you are likely to feel,
seeing what the world's lurch
has brought to light.
Thrusting up beliefs and desires you had
assumed belonged to an earlier stage
of human development.
What is this stuff you ask one another
and how can it still be kicking around
given how much we already know?
It looks like the kind of relics that
archeologists dig up and dust off,
speculating about the beliefs
that once had animated them
to the best that they can
be reconstructed.
Gone as they are now,
those thrashings of proto
rationality and mythical,
magical hypothesizing
and nearly forgotten.
Now it's all gone unforgotten and minds
that have better things to think about
have to divert precious
neuronal resources
to figuring out how to knock
some sense back into the species.
It's a tiresome proposition having to
take up the work of the Enlightenment
all over again
but it's happened on your watch.
You ought to have sent up a balloon
now and then to get a read
on the prevailing cognitive conditions.
The Thinks watching out
for the Think Nots.
Now you've gone and let the stockpiling
of fallacies reach dangerous levels
and the mass weapons of the illogic are
threatening the survivability of the globe.
None of this is particularly
good for the world
but it has been good for Cass Seltzer.
That's what he's thinking
at this moment
gazing down at the frozen river
and regarding the improbable
swerve his life has lately taken.
He's thinking his life has gotten better
because the world has gone bonkers.
He's thinking zealots proliferate
and Seltzer prospers.
It's 4:00 AM and Cass Seltzer
is standing on Weeks Bridge,
the graceful arc that spans the Charles
River near Harvard University,
staring down at the river below,
which is in the rigor mortis of
late February in New England.
The whole vista is deserted
beyond vacancy,
deserted in the way of being
inhospitable to human life.
There's not a car passing
on Memorial Drive,
and the elegant river dorms
are darkened to silent hulks,
the most hyper kinetic of undergraduates
sedated to purring girls and boys.
It's not like Cass Seltzer to be
out in the middle of an icy night,
lost in thought while losing
sensation in his extremities.
Excitement had gotten the better of him.
He had lain in his bed for hours,
mind racing,
until he gave up and crawled out
from under the luxe comforter
that his girlfriend Lucinda Mandelbaum
had brought with her
when she moved in with him recently.
This comforter has pockets
for the hands and feet
and a softness that's the result of
impregnation with aloe vera.
As a man,
Cass had been skeptical,
but he's become a begrudging
believer in Lucinda's comforter,
and in her Tempur Pedic pillow, too,
suffused with the fragrance
of her coconut shampoo,
making it all the more remarkable
that he'd forsake his bed
for this no man's stretch
of frigid night.
Rummaging in the front closet
for some extra protection,
he had pulled out
a long forgotten item,
the tricolor scarf that
his ex-wife, Pascale,
had learned to knit for him
during the four months
when she was recovering from aphasia,
four months that had produced,
along with other shockers,
an excessively long French flag
of a wool scarf,
which he wound seven and
a half times around his neck
before heading out into the dark
to deal with the rush in his head.
Lucinda's away tonight,
away for the entire bleak week to come.
Cass is missing Lucinda in his bones,
missing her in the marrow that's
presently crystallizing into ice.
She's in warmer climes,
at a conference in Santa Barbara
on 'Non-Nash Equilibria
in Zero-Sum Games.'
Among these equilibria is one that's
called the 'Mandelbaum Equilibrium,'
and it's Cass' ambition to have
the Mandelbaum Equilibrium
mastered by the time he picks her
up from the airport Friday night.
Technically,
Lucinda's a psychologist,
like Cass,
only not like Cass at all.
Her work is so mathematical that
almost no one would suspect it
has anything to do with mental life.
Cass, on the other hand,
is about as far away on the continuum as
you can get and still be in the same field.
He's so far away that he is
knee-deep in the swampy humanities.
For close to two decades
Cass Seltzer has all but owned
the psychology of religion,
but only because nobody else wanted it,
but now things had happened.
Fundamental and fundamentalist things,
and religion as a phenomenon
is on everybody's mind.
And among all the changes that
religion's new towering profile
has wrought in the world,
which are mostly alarming
if not downright terrifying,
is the transformation in
the life of one Cass Seltzer.
First had come the book,
which he had entitled The Varieties
of Religious Illusion.
The book had brought Cass
an indecent amount of attention.
Time Magazine,
in a cover story on the so called new atheists,
had singled him out as
the only one among them
who seemed to have any idea of
what it feels like to be a believer
and it ended by dubbing him
'the atheist with a soul'.
Next had come the girl,
although that designation hardly
does justice to the situation,
not when the situation stands for
the likes of Lucinda Mandelbaum,
known in her world as
'The Goddess of Game Theory.'
And now, only today,
as if his cup weren't
already gushing over,
had come a letter from Harvard,
laying out its intention of luring him
away from Frankfurter University,
located in nearby Weedham,
Massachusetts.
Cass has the letter on him right
now baring the insignia of Veritas,
zippered into an inside
pocket of his parka,
insulating him against the cold.
The night is so frigid that everything
seems to have been stripped bare
of superfluous existence,
reduced to the purity of abstraction.
Cass has the distinct impression that
he can see better in the sharpened air,
and takes off his glasses and
of course can hardly see a thing
past the nimbus phantom
of his own breath.
But then he stares harder and
it seems that he can see better,
that the world has slipped
into sharper focus.
It's only now that he catches
sight of this spectacle
that the extreme cold has
created in the river blow,
frozen solid except where its
forced through the three arches
of the bridges substructure,
creating an effect that could
reasonably be called sublime,
and in the Kantian sense:
not cozily beautiful, but touched
by a metaphysical chill.
The quickened water has sculpted
three immense and perfect arches
into the solid ice,
soaring fifty or sixty feet to their apices,
sublime almost as if by design.
Standing dead center on Weeks Bridge,
in the dead of winter in the dead of night,
staring down at the sublime formation,
Cass is contemplating the strange
thing that his life has become.
To him.
His life has become strange to him.
He feels as if he's wearing
somebody else's coat,
grabbed in a hurry
after a boozy party.
He's walking around in someone
else's bespoke cashmere
while that guy's got Cass's
hooded parka,
and only Cass seems to
have noticed the switch.
What has happened is that Cass Seltzer
has become an intellectual celebrity.
He's become famous
for his abstract ideas.
And not just any old abstract ideas,
but atheist abstract ideas,
which makes him,
according to some of the latest polls,
a spokesperson for the most
distrusted minority in America,
the one that most Americans are least
willing to allow their children to marry.
This is a fact.
Studies have found that a large
proportion of Americans rate atheists
below Muslims, recent immigrants,
gays, Jews, and Communists
in quote 'sharing their vision
of America' un-quote.
Cass Seltzer has become the unlikely
poster boy for this mistrusted group.
His is a good face for counteracting the
fallacy of equating godlessness with vice.
Cass' fundamental niceness
is written all over him.
He's got a strong jaw,
a high ovoid forehead from
which his floppy auburn hair
is only just slightly receding,
and the sweetest,
most earnest smile this side
of Oral Roberts University.
The atheist with a soul.
Cass always smiles at
the absurdity of the phrase.
But which is the more absurd element?
The truth is, and what's
the good of a man contemplating
an inhumanly frozen world at 4 a.m.
if no truth-telling ensues,
that Cass is somewhat at a loss
to account for what he's done.
How to explain those 36 Arguments for
the Existence of God (see Appendix),
all of them formally constructed
in the preferred analytic mode,
premises parading with military precision
and every shirking presupposition
and sketchy implication
forced out into the open
and subjected to rigorous inspection.
Cass had started out with all the standard
arguments for God's existence,
the ones discussed in philosophy
classes and textbooks:
The Cosmological Argument (#1),
The Ontological Argument (#2),
The Classical Teleological Argument (#3A),
the arguments from Miracles,
Moral Truths,
and Mysticism (#11, 16,
and 22, respectively),
Pascal's Wager (#31) ,
and William James' Argument
from Pragmatism (#32).
He had analyzed the new
batch of arguments
recently whipped up by the intelligent
design crowd, to wit,
The Argument from Irreducible
Complexity (#3B),
The Argument from the Paucity
of Benign Mutations (# 3C),
The Argument from The Original
Replicator (#3D),
The Argument from The Big Bang (#4),
The Argument from the Fine-Tuning
of the Physical Constants (#5),
and The Argument from the Hard
Problem of Consciousness (#12).
But he had gone beyond these too,
attempting to polish up into
genuine arguments
those religious intuitions and emotions
that are often powerfully evocative
but too sub-syllogistic to be regarded
as actual arguments.
He had tried to capture under
the net of analytic reason
those fleeting shadows cast
by unseen winged things
darting through the thick foliage
of the religious sensibility.
So, for example,
he had formulated the Argument
from the Improbable Self (#13).
Struggling to squeeze into precision the
sense of paradox that he knows too well,
the flailing attempt to calm
the inside outside vertigo
to which he's given at odd
moments in his life
but which he can always reliably
bring upon himself by staring too long
at the improbable fact of his being
identical with himself.
If somebody hasn't personally experienced
this particular kind of
metaphysical seizure
then it's hard to find the words
to give a sense of what it's like.
Cass had experienced it even as a boy,
lying in bed and thinking his way into
the sense of the strangeness
of being just this.
Cass had had the lower bunk bed.
Both he and Jesse, his younger brother,
had wanted the higher bunk,
but, as usual,
Jesse had wanted what he wanted so
much more than Cass had wanted it,
with a fury of need that was
exhausting just to watch,
that Cass had let it go.
Lying there awake on his lower bunk,
Cass would think about being
himself and not being Jesse.
There was Jesse,
and here was Cass.
But if someone else were
looking at the two of them,
Jesse there,
Cass here,
how could that person tell that he, Cass,
was Cass here and not Jesse there?
If it got switched on them,
everything the same about them,
the body and memories and sense
of self and everything else,
only now he was Jesse here
and there was Cass there,
how would anybody know?
How would he know,
how would Jesse?
Maybe a switch had already happened,
maybe it happened again and again,
and how could anybody tell?
The longer he tried to get a fix
on the fact of being Cass here,
the more the whole idea of
it just got away from him.
If he tried long enough to grasp it,
then he could get the fact
of being Cass here
to just blank out of existence and
then come dribbling weakly back in,
like a fluorescent fixture
flickering on and off toward death.
He would get the sense of
having been shot out of himself
and now was someone
who was regarding his being
Cass Seltzer
as something like his being
in the sixth grade,
just something about him
that happened to be true.
Who was that Other that he was who
was regarding his being Cass Seltzer
as if he didn't have to be Cass Seltzer?
The sense of giddiness induced by these
exercises could be a bit too overwhelming
for a kid in a lower bunk bed.
It could be a bit overwhelming still.
'Here I am,' Cass is saying,
standing on Weeks Bridge and talking
aloud into the sublimely indifferent night.
Cass knows he needs to tamp down his
tendencies toward the transcendent.
It isn't becoming in America's
favorite atheist,
who is, at this moment,
Cass Seltzer,
who is, somehow or other,
just this here.
'Here I am.'
How can it be that,
of all things,
one is this thing,
so that one can say,
astonishingly,
in the right frame of mind,
it is astonishing,
with the metaphysical
chill blowing in from afar,
'Here I am.'
When you didn't force yourself to
think in formal reconstructions,
when you didn't catch these
moments of ravishments
under the lens of premises
and conclusions,
when you didn't impale them
and label them,
like so many splayed butterflies,
bleeding the transcendental
glow right out of them, then what?
It's even hard at a time like this to resist
the shameful narcissistic appeal
of reasonings like The Argument
from Personal Coincidences (#8)
and The Argument from
Answered Prayers (#9)
A Wonderful Life (#10).
William James had rebuked the quote
'scroundel logic' un-quote
that calculates divine provenance from
one's own little goody bag of gains,
and Cass couldn't agree more
with the spirit of James,
but here it is,
his bulging goody bag,
and call him a scoundrel for being
personally grateful to the universe
when at this same moment that
he is standing on Weeks Bridge
and tossing hosannas out into
the infinite universe,
there are at this same time
multitudes of others
whose lives are painfully
constricting with misfortunes
that are just as arbitrary and undeserved
as his own expansive good luck,
but Cass Seltzer does feel grateful.
At moments like this could Cass
altogether withstand the sense that,
hard to put it into words,
the sense that the universe is personal,
that there is something personal
that grounds existence and order
and value and purpose and meaning,
and that the grandeur of the personal
universe has somehow infiltrated
and is expanding his own small person,
bringing his littleness more
into line with its grandeur,
that the personal universe has
been personally kind to him,
gracious and forgiving,
to Cass Seltzer,
gratuitously, exorbitantly,
divinely kind,
and this despite Cass' having,
with callowness and
shallowness aforethought,
thrown spitballs at the whole
idea of cosmic intentionality?
No, that doesn't capture it either.
Those words are far too narrowed
by Cass' own particular life,
when what it is he could feel,
has felt,
might even be feeling now,
has nothing to do with the contents
of Cass' existence,
but rather with existence itself.
This, this, this,
what?
This expansion out into the world
which is a kind of love, he supposes,
a love for the whole of existence,
that could so easily well up
in Cass Seltzer at this moment,
standing here in the pure
abstractions of this night
and contemplating the strange
thisness of his life
when viewed sub specie aeternitatis,
that is to say from the vantage
point of eternity
which comes so highly recommended
to us by Spinoza.
Here it is then: the sense that existence
is just such a tremendous thing,
one comes into it, astonishingly,
here one is,
formed by biology and history,
genes and culture,
in the midst of the contingency
of the world,
here one is, one doesn't know how,
one doesn't know why,
and suddenly one doesn't know where
one is either or who or what one is either,
and all that one knows is
that one is a part of it,
a considered and conscious part of it,
generated and sustained in existence
in ways one can hardly comprehend,
all the time conscious of it,
though, of existence,
the fullness of it,
the reaching expanse and
pulsing intricacy of it,
and one wants to live in a way that
at least begins to do justice to it,
one wants to expand one's reach of it
as far as expansion is possible
and even beyond that, to live one's life
in a way commensurate
with the privilege of being
a part of and conscious of
the whole reeling glorious
infinite sweep,
a sweep that includes,
so improbably,
a psychologist of religion
named Cass Seltzer,
who moved by powers beyond himself,
did something more improbable than
all the improbabilities constituting
his improbable existence
could have entailed,
did something that won him
someone else's life,
a better life,
a more brilliant life,
a life beyond all the ones he had wished
for in the pounding obscurity
of all his yearnings,
because all of this,
this,
couldn't belong to him,
to the man who stands on Weeks Bridge,
wrapped round in a scarf
his once-beloved ex-wife Pascale had
knit for him for some necessary reason
that he would never know,
perhaps to offer him some protection
against the desolation
she knew would soon be his,
and was,
but is no longer,
suspended here above sublimity,
his cheeks aflame with
either euphoria or frostbite,
a letter in his zippered pocket
with the Imprimatur of Veritas
and a Lucinda Mandelbaum
with whom to share it all."
Thank you.
[applause]
So,
that's what an atheist
with a soul looks like.
Are there any questions?
>> I'll ask a question.
Rebecca: Thank you.
>> Can I go to the podium?
>> Alright.
>> Hello.
Rebecca: Hi.
>> The Existence of God seems
more semantic then substantive
and that the definition of God or
cosmic intentionality is watered down .
The real interesting point there as well,
that God must exist.
The real question is: What is God?
Not does God exist?
Does that make sense?
Rebecca: That makes total
sense so in this very active,
contemporary debate between
so called new atheists
or just atheists and believers,
what's the substance here?
When people declare themselves
as atheists,
what are they denying the existence of?
Just about anything can
be defined as God,
including as my heroes
Spinoza defined it,
the final theory of everything.
The theory that's going to explain
why the laws of nature
are the laws of nature and why
they had to be realized in this world
so what's the substance of
calling yourself an atheist?
And I think here's-
here is what they have in mind,
or what we have in mind,
when we deny.
It's the notion of a transcendent being,
something that exists outside
of the laws of nature,
outside of space and time,
matter and energy,
and that willed the world into existence,
willed the laws of nature to be the
ones that they are and moreover,
laid down the laws of morality,
just grounded the difference between
right and wrong and moreover,
whose purpose is meant
to be our purpose.
That we're meant to understand
our own lives in terms of the purpose
of this transcendent moral creator.
So that's the idea.
When people, I think,
are denying the existence of God,
they're denying the existence
of that ontology.
>> Umm,
it sounds like when you talk about
God moreover you say
that God is definitely a subset of,
we're told personal gods.
Gods that have a set of
characteristics of a person
having will or intention or thought
and excluding other forms of
God that are more exotic.
And I think that there are a handful of
religions where their concept of god
is actually making it mostly exotic,
so it sounds like this is more or less
related about Western religion
and its values as opposed to
something worldwide.
Rebecca: Yeah. So it really is about this
contemporary debate that's going on,
you know?
That it's suddenly,
and it's quite interesting to a philosopher
to have this sort of philosophical discussion,
that you talk about in
your philosophy classes
suddenly taken over the public square to
be so much involved in public discussion
so it's really about that debate
and the denial of
that particular very Western
conception of God.
And all of the 36 arguments that
are in the appendix worked out
and I tried to give them
the best form possible
because it's no good
to rebut arguments
unless you make them
the very best possible
so I really try to work them up
as well as I can.
They are all, except for one, #35,
but all the other ones are for
the notion of a transcendent God,
a very Western notion of God.
The kind of God that the popular
monotheistic religions recognize:
Christianity, Judaism, and Islam
so it's really that conception and these are
arguments for the existence of that God.
The one exception is #35 which is
the Argument for Spinoza's God
and that's basically an argument
for a nontranscendent God.
It's a god who is imminent in the world
and who is basically identical to
the final theory of everything
so that's the one exception.
That's the more exotic God and that one
has also played a role in Western culture,
Western history of ideas,
so I include it,
but yeah,
it's not-, it's about this debate
going on now
and therefore it's about
the Western conception of God.
>> Thanks.
Rebecca: Thank you.
>> So it makes a lot of sense that your
protagonist is a psychologist because,
so instead the key question is why do people
buy into this mythology kind of thinking
when the rationale doesn't sway
them or whatever
and they keep going that way
Rebecca: I would love to hear
you explain it and see
how close it is to Cass'
explanation of why.
>> Umm, well,
it seems to me it's a cult curiosity
and it's obviously selected once a
species gets past a certain point where
knowing how becomes
a survival advantage
so it's a set of genes that
cause one to instinctually
and I'm using the word
instinct highly,
they manifest themselves
as a feeling of discomfort
when confronted with answers with
the good book in front of questions
which you don't have answers.
It's the otherside of
the exploratory instinct,
of curiosity,
so something as important
as what happens after death.
The absence of an answer
to that question produces
such an uncomfortable feeling because
of your inherited called species memory.
It causes such an uncomfortable
feeling that it can't be tolerated
so answers must be invented rather
than saying, "Gee, I don't know."
Rebecca: I think that's actually
a large part of that
and so many of the arguments
in the appendix
are this is an irresolvable dilemma.
This is the argument for free will and
the argument of survival after that
and just a bunch of arguments.
The arguments for moral truths
and things that we don't quite
have a clear cut, not quite
well we don't have a clear cut
answer to,
and it's a kind of substitution
of one mystery for another
so we'll bury this mystery
and the mystery of God
and that this will provide an answer.
I think that that's part of that and either
Cass or I call it the Ontological Urge.
I don't remember if it was
his term or mine.
If I actually invented a piece
of it in the book
but in any case one of us calls it
this Ontological Urge.
You know, here we are,
you know?
And we are capable of self consciousness,
of forming an idea of ourselves
and of the universe
and trying to,
and of asking these questions about
the universe and our relationship to it
and wanting answers and the intolerability
of the lack of answers
that are forthcoming really does sit
very, very uncomfortably
and I think that's also part of it.
That's part of it but I think there's more.
One of the things that Cass thinks
as a psychologist of religion
is that the religious impulse
the religious reaction is complicated
so that for example some of our
inherited feelings of disgust
also finds an outlet
in the religious emotions.
The notion of spiritual purity is a way
of also doing justice to this notion
of disgust which has great survival value.
We feel disgust at things that
carry germs or whatever
and it becomes, given the kinds
of abstract makers that we are,
it becomes more abstract
and so there is a notion
of the body itself being
impure of other people
being carriers of impurity.
This too finds an outlet in
certain religious emotions.
Tribalism finds who we can trust,
who are those that share our values,
finds an outlet in religious emotions.
It's complicated so there's
certainly the ontological origins.
So many of the actual arguments
for the existence of God
that Cass explores in his appendix.
It's actually the appendix of his book deal
with this discomfort that you have located
when answers are not forthcoming
but to get back to the question
that he's a psychologist of religion,
I've been asked quite a few times
why has new atheism emerged recently,
in basically the last ten years.
There have been these big books,
I mean Dennett and Dawkins
and Sam Harris
and Christopher Hitchins
and many others.
Why now?
And I think part of it is
the obvious answer, what,
the violence that has occurred in more
extreme and zealot forms of religions
so it's not just this cozy,
sweet little thing but it's the more violent
and virulent forms that have emerged
but also I do think the progress
that's been made in psychology,
in particular in evolutionary
psychology,
we've already been sort of throwing off
some sort of evolutionary psychological
explanations for religion so when
you want to argue against something,
it's never enough to just show
that the arguments don't work,
that they fail,
but the next part of it is to show why people
would nevertheless continue to believe
and evolutionary psychology has
now been able to tackle that
and give us answers to that.
That's a very, for those of you
who read David Hume,
who is a great hero to
free thinkers everywhere,
his way of arguing against a position
is always first you show
there's no argument for it.
The arguments fail the cause of the idea
of necessary connection for example,
that he went after in a big way,
and then the second half
is to turn to psychology.
You find this move all the time
in David Hume and to say,
"Look, here is why nevertheless we
have an almost irresistible impulse
to believe in this thing."
He didn't have, of course,
evolutionary psychology at his
disposal in the 18th century,
but that's that kind of mood so yeah,
I made my guy a psychologist
of religion
because that's where the second
half of this kind of argument
is coming from and if you
actually look at those
who have been at the forefront of
arguing atheism, this pushback,
it's coming from people in evolutionary
biology or evolutionary psychology
and I think that it's a measure of the
strength of the behavioral sciences.
That they now have something to say
about the psychology of religion.
It's the second half of that argument
so that's why he's a psychologist
of religion.
>> When Voltaire had said,
"If God did not exist,
that man would have to invent him."
in less sexist form,
I think that he was trying to say
we are constantly seeking a way
to explain the unexplainable
and I just wondered if you were
familiar with this book called
"Why God Won't Go Away"
and talking about the biological
basis of beliefs
and some of the experiments
you're just referring to
evolutionary biology and psychology
some of the experiments that were
done with near death experiences
where people had a religious
experience also on psychedelics
and various other things
and they were finding that
there is a biological basis for
why people believe these things
but there was another explanation
other than deities and gods.
I wonder if you are familiar with his
work and if it influenced you work.
Rebecca: I don't know that
particular work.
I did read a lot about experiments of
this sort and explanations of this sort.
I will read this work now
but it is too late,
you might say [laughing] but
I think we have it covered.
But,
I mean, clearly,
here's one of the things.
In that first chapter,
I sort of show you going through
a kind of spiritual experience
and it is the kind of experience
that Spinoza talks about,
this intellectual love of God,
but you nevertheless resist trying to
explain this experience in religious terms,
in terms of that transcendent other thing
that you are confronting in this experience.
You stop with existence itself.
What a tremendous thing
existence itself is
and even sometimes a kind of
gratitude that I think we've all felt.
I know in studying physics,
I was always overwhelmed
that the laws of physics
are just so beautiful and you feel
this sort of something,
or mathematical proof
or music or art.
This something that
takes you out of yourself
and you feel your own smallness
in relation to the grandeur
and you almost can get
swallowed up in it and it's grand,
it's marvelous.
It's a kind of feeling of transcendence.
I think for some reason that evolutionary
psychologists have not yet
been able to explain
we have this capacity
and in fact creativity
gives us this capacity.
It's an intensifying of this feeling.
I think good things come from this,
romantic love can give it to one too
and good things can sometimes
even come from romantic love.
I hear tell, no
It is very natural to put that into religious
terms I think as a kind of metaphor,
and even Cass says that this
universe has been exorbitantly,
gratuitously,
divinely kind.
It's very, very easy to,
that's the vocabulary that
we have available to us
that we've sort of inherited,
And, so it's very, very, easy
to slip into that metaphor
and then to be mislead
by I think one's metaphor
and that's a kind of Vickensteinian
notion that you know
you can be misled by your metaphors.
It fits in certain ways,
it doesn't fit in other ways,
that's why it's a metaphor
but you get misled and you go off
in these other directions.
I tend to think of a lot of
religiosity as that,
being misled by one's metaphors.
However,
I shouldn't be saying what I think,
Cass thinks.
The wonderful thing about writing
novels rather than philosophy
is I don't have to defend the views.
It's my character but yes,
he does feel that so when he gets
carried off by these experiences,
he nevertheless will resist the urge
to go one step beyond
and see this as an experience
and evidence for God.
>> So this is a little bit related
to what you've been saying.
So most of the conversation we've been
having here is about the arguments for
and against God and why they have
to know and all that kind of stuff.
Why is it that you decided to
write this novel
instead of writing varieties
of religious allusion?
I assume it's not just so you can
back away from the arguments?
Rebecca: Well, I am a coward
[laughs]
but I do sometimes go on the line
and stand by my beliefs.
I got very, my last book,
in fact my last two books,
had been nonfiction.
One was on Godel's Incompleteness
Theorems;
"Incompleteness: The Proof
and the Paradox of Kurt Godel"
and then the next one was on Spinoza,
"Betraying Spinoza: The Renegade Jew
Who Gave Us Modernity"
and both of those books are
in fact parts of series
and I'd been asked to write
about them so
I wrote about them.
Partly as a result of publishing
the Spinoza book,
I got very drawn into this new debate
between atheists and believers
and drawn into the movement
of the new atheists.
Spinoza is really,
he's a hero to free thinkers,
so I got invited to give talks
to organizations,
associations of pro science,
pro reason,
sometimes more or less
anti religious groups
and I'm on Sam Harris's board
for The Reason Foundation.
I just, as a result, got drawn into this
and it interested me very much
but I felt that something was
being left out of the discussion.
There is something about,
part of these differences
of opinion have to do
with very different experiences
of the world,
or sometimes very much the same
sort of experiences
but different language that
you're putting to this experience
and so for religious people,
sometime it seemed that those
who were denying God
or denying any kind of
spiritual expansion,
any kind of transcendence so it seemed
to me important to present an atheist
who is very capable of
this sort of experience,
and on the other side among those
whom I very much agree with in fact,
the new atheists,
sometimes a tendency to not do
justice to the complexity
of the religious emotion and that
it has to do with other things,
why is this sentence not coming out?
It has to do with things other
than the belief in God
and demonstrating the fallacies in these arguments often don't do anything at all.
It has to do sometimes with
these existential dilemmas
that one simply cannot tolerate.
It has to do with often feelings
of affinity with certain people
or with family loyalties
or a certain narrative.
It's a complicated business and whenever
I feel like some philosophical issue
is very tied in with different ways
of experiencing the world,
I always get driven to write a novel.
I mean, almost against my will
because it seems to me that is
what the novel is made for.
It's made for exploring how the world
feels to different characters.
That's how you create
a character in a novel.
It's really a world view
and of what the world feels like
to each of these characters
and so since this debate seemed
to me the more I got into it,
the more it seemed to me that it had
a lot to do with just world's colliding.
The world is simply very, very different
for these different people
and they are talking past each other
and sometimes agreeing
more than they realize.
I'd have to write a novel about it and
also another thing that I'm committed to,
again it's a very Spinozist idea,
is that cognition and emotion are not
as separated from each other
as we in Western philosophy
have assumed.
That there is a way of experiencing
emotionally certain truths
that gives it a kind of substance
and makes it one's own in a way
that pure cognition doesn't
and this kind of Tony Damasio's
view of what is the book,
searching for Spinoza,
looking for Spinoza,
Tony Damasio, a neuroscientist
who says it's coming out of his labs,
verification of this Spinozistic view
that the emotions and the intellect
are not as separated
as we've assumed
and what you can do in a novel that
you are simply not allowed to do
in analytic philosophy is infuse emotions
and to show how these intellectual views
are also connected with the emotional life
and you simply can't do that in the kind
of philosophy in which I'm trained
so I do it in novels and
it actually can bring the reader,
give the reader a participation in a
emotion that they would normally not have
so I've actually had some of my friends
from the atheist movement say that
they just really never even knew what it
felt like when people are talking about,
when they are talking about spiritual
experiences and now they know.
Somehow going through it with
Cass in his very secular way
gave them some sort of understanding
of what it would be like to be drawn out of
yourself in this kind of transcendent way,
so that for me is great validation
of the power of fiction.
We're done.
[applause]